well when it comes to woodworking our
next guest
is really nailing it yeah
she is too i did such a deep dive into
all her work and it's just really on
point i'm very excited to be speaking
with her ashley bass knight creator of
the super successful blog
handmade haven has made it her mission
to give women
the tools that's right you heard me to
make everything from coat hooks to
coffee tables in just a few simple steps
please welcome ashley hi ashley how are
you
[Applause]
good to meet you how did you get
interested in this how did this come
about
i asked this as a woman who during the
pandemic literally got sick of myself
feeling like a damsel in distress and
started taking on
more like household jobs but i have to
admit when i see this
i know it's not a blow dryer and i've
always wanted to work with this
can you please please be my entry point
into a new life
of course i'm so here to help so four
years ago i actually just stumbled over
to work i was just coming
to my new house and i wanted a new
kitchen table but i couldn't find anyone
to build one so i was like you know what
i'm gonna make one myself
and i did and it turned out great and it
just started a woodworking journey
i mean i was excited that i fixed a
toilet i don't know if i would have
the you know cajones to like literally
start making furniture it's so bold but
what i love
about your website in particular is i
love a before and after i think we're
all suckers for that
and i really love how you rework spaces
and the way you
show how it's doable and possible so
today you're going to be
showing us how to make a wooden coat
rack which i was very excited that we
were going to tackle this because
this is a must-have in all homes so what
should we do
first so first we're going to start by
painting so get your paint ready get
your colors we're gonna just take a
paintbrush you know
dip it in there you know and just start
painting
okay i got that i got that and there's a
nice
preset for me yes
yes yes yes see sam did this preset
that's why it looks 10 times better good
for you see i'm
making me look good but i got to give
you all the credit
all right now we got that
in there okay we gotta let it dry okay
so we can move on to our um preset
beautiful yellow plank that sam made
beautiful sam
and by the way sam is that girl like
she's crafty she's
cute she's like the complete package
every time i see her i'm like
i just marvel and this is a super simple
beginner project anybody can tackle
i have to say i really like painting
with this phone number it's this is
really pleasant
all right what's next ashley because i
i want to get right into this let's face
facts like let's place hooks
let's get into it so we're going to add
these hooks here you're going to
take our little drill get your screw in
there
okay i'm going to move this
big wet piece of wood and i'm gonna get
into here okay i am so excited this is
gonna be
my first time doing this and i'm not
gonna lie it's
it's something that i've always wanted
to do oh this yeah typical fashion of me
this is already going terribly
ashley what what do i need to do here
that i'm not doing
so if you just hold the screw to the
hole really firmly
and then put the drill on there
oh my god this is the first and it was
so
good
sorry next all right and just drill in
those four holes just to make sure that
the coat hook is nice and firm into the
wood
oh no okay you know what that's okay
that's okay i i
okay okay oh gosh you got this you got
it
you know what i should have just stopped
while i was ahead
all right you know what what's next okay
because we are running out of time and i
want to make sure
that people also know that they can
personalize this which i thought was
really sweet
so a fun way to personalize it is by
using some like glitter letters or
something you can put a nice sink
or your initials you know just make it
personable make it your own
i am going to put my daughter's names so
that they have sort of like a designated
this is your side this is
you know your sister's side and then
they can fight about it all they want
but the
writings on the coat hook if you know
what i mean
i'm doing a fun thing
you know i couldn't really hear that
ashley our connection's a little bit
fuzzy but i just want to say that when
you're done
it looks like this and as i said i did a
deep dive on your website and you made
everything look so beautiful
oh i love that multicolored
ashley you're so cool and i have total
admiration for you
and although my first time went amazing
and my second time went
a little i'm gonna get this and you have
set me free
in life and i'm so excited because i
think that
women definitely need to be able to see
power tools and not be intimidated
right
um ashley you are an absolute
inspiration
and i thank you so
thank you ashley you have changed my
life and you are changing other women's
lives because i know
that that is a very important cause to
you is to take
care of women and show them all their
possibilities and you are leading the
charge and we thank you for it and love
shining a light on you
and thank you so much for being on the
show today
thank you ashley best night
[Music]